my standards of the twenties well you
know I didn't believe in weekends back
then not to mention vacations when we
started off with we literally only had
like one computer and so would be a web
server during the day and I'd code at
night we're asked about work-life
balance all the time and my view is
that's a debilitating phrase because it
it implies there's a strict trade-off
and the reality is if I'm happy at home
I come into the office with tremendous
energy want to be happy
build a life not just a business
hey seven Carmichael and this channel
was created to help you overcome the
number one challenge that is holding you
back a lack of belief in yourself you
watch these videos because you know
there's something greater inside you two
you've got Michael Jordan level talent
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn the seven
best lessons from Elon Musk Warren
Buffett and other billionaires
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one love what you do with Bill Gates
most people over the last 200 years or
so who wherever they the wealthiest
person the world was didn't usually work
that hard when they got to be sixty or
so they kind of took life easy you seem
to be working pretty hard what motivates
you to still work so hard well I love my
work the work of the foundation is super
interesting I get to meet with the
scientists I get to go out in the field
I do think your habits are sort of set
in your 20s and 30s and by my standards
of the twenties well you know I didn't
believe in weekends back then
not to mention vacations so I'm you know
fairly lazy compared to myself in my 20s
where I was a true fanatic you know all
I believed in was working on software
night and day and and for my 20s that
was perfect I didn't have a wife or
family at all and my rule was very hint
hands on roll rule number two don't
compare yourself to others with Oprah
Winfrey that show was on for 25 years in
Chicago and when you did it you won I
think almost 50 Emmy Awards and it was
voted one of the best TV shows in the
history of TV so you ended it though if
for 25 years to do other things and
we'll talk about that but you know
regrets about ending that show no no we
got no regrets whatsoever you know I
didn't want to be punched drunk in the
ring still trying to come up with what
is the next thing what is the next thing
because over the years we became our own
greatest competition so when I first
started went national in 1986 every time
there'd be another talk show via
Geraldo Rivera what are we gonna do and
then I realized a couple of years in
that you run your own race better than
anybody if you take the time to see what
everybody else is doing you lose your
ground and that I could be a better me
than I could be anybody else and so no
need to trying to compare myself to
other people rule number three be
persistent with Elon Musk when I started
the first Internet companies up to with
my brother and another person a great
curry the it wasn't really with the
thought of being wealthy it you know
nothing against being wealthy but but
it's just it was just from the
standpoint I've been wanting to be part
of the Internet and I figured if we
could make enough money to just get by I
would be that would be okay and when we
started off with we literally only had
like one computer and so it'll be our
web server during the day and I'd code
at night and we just got a small office
in Palo Alto back when rent was not
insane and it cost us like 150 dollars a
month and was cheaper than an apartment
so we actually just slept in the office
and then [ __ ] and then shower at the
YMCA a page from El Camino so we'd walk
her over there and and shower and and
that was actually I think it was when I
first I first met you by the way and so
I don't know how many people know but
probably any people knows but we
actually pitched Steve in like January
96 on that the zip to business plan and
actually I thought he was actually one
of the most up to speed on on what
actually was in our business plan most
most the people we met did not actually
read our business plan in fact a lot of
people were let her bench capsule she
met at the time didn't even know what
the internet was well I've never never
youth they never used my sure like you
know sort of well-known people in Sand
Hill I was like wow okay but but at the
time nobody made any any money on the
internet so I guess that's you know did
then it wasn't really clear evidence
that that there was was a business
also if you want to learn from
billionaires everyday get more self-love
and confidence check out my 254 series
they're free the links join on the
description below
starting companies like staring at the
abyss and eating glass but if you ask me
to write a story on what is Potomac
Electric Power there's something like
that I can write the story and that's
what I'm doing every day I'm assigning
myself a story and that I go out and you
really have to believe the Internet's
going to be mainstream rule number four
build work life harmony with Jeff Bezos
this work life harmony thing is what I
try to teach young employees actually in
senior executives at Amazon - but
especially the people come in I get
where asked about work-life balance all
the time
and my view is that's a debilitating
phrase because it it implies there's a
strict trade-off and the reality is if
I'm happy at home I come into the office
with tremendous energy and if I'm happy
at work I come home with tremendous
energy and so it actually is a circle
it's not a balance and and I think that
that is it's worth everybody paying
attention to you want happier you never
want to be that guy and we all know we
all have a co-worker who is that person
who as soon as they come into the
meeting they drain all of the energy out
of the room you can just feel the energy
level go that you don't want to be that
guy so you want to come into the office
and give everybody a kick in their step
rule number five start small with Warren
Buffett you have over a hundred billion
dollars of cash Berkshire does Berkshire
has over one hundred billion in cash and
you say that you always want this
company to be a fortress so how much
cash should an ordinary investor have on
a percentage basis depends it depends on
our personal situation I've had it if if
you if you're working and something
where you're living off your your your
paycheck from week to week you want to
have a little cash or how long then and
you certainly don't want to have a
credit card that's maxed out or anything
like that but if
you know if your house is paid off if
you don't have big living expenses
you got a portfolio of decent
diversified businesses we need any cash
rule number six give people
opportunities with Mark Zuckerberg one
of the things that I think we've done
well is is just given the people at the
company a lot of opportunity right so
you know it's not just me who started
when I was 19 and and now you know I'm
running this big company there were a
number of people who joined who were you
know people I did problem sets with at
Harvard or they dropped out of Stanford
or you know different programs who've
grown with the company over this long
period of time and you know one of the
things that I'm the most proud of is we
have about 12 different product groups
of the company and all of the people who
are running them with the exception of
one did not join the company of running
a product group or reporting to me
that's amazing and the one exception was
his David Marcus who was the CEO of a
fifty billion dollar public company so
you know some pretty happy that that
that he's on board and having him run a
product group I think is a pretty big
coup too but literally none of them
started off reporting to me you know
they all start off in different
different roles some where engineers
some where data analysts some where
product managers and they've all grown
but I think what happens is you know
people see that you create opportunities
for people and and that also I think
keeps the best people engaged and makes
the best people want to come work at
your company because they feel like oh
I'm gonna get those kind of
opportunities too and you'll number
seven the last one before a very special
bonus clip is try hard with Jack Ma I
think everybody can be successful if you
really try a try a hard I study I leave
over nineteen ninety nine in my
apartment I talked to the 18th funders
that one thing we want one of the things
we want to prove if Jack - team can be
successful 80% of the people in the
world they can be successful because we
don't have money would have technology
we don't have almost nothing the only
thing is that we believe in the future
and start to do little by little
now I've got a really special bonus clip
with Mark Cuban on how to always keep
learning that I think you're gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day I want to know where
do you need to build work life harmony
what does that look like for you let me
know down the comments below
and if you made it this far in a video
you're still here watching then you
promise you commit to yourself that
you're gonna take action we don't just
watch videos here believe nation we do
something about it give me a hashtag
believed on the comments below if that's
you so I can celebrate with you too
now I'm going through and teaching
myself neural networks and you know
doing the same thing with machine
learning and Gans and this and that
because AI is going to have more of an
impact than the internet did AI plus new
types of chipsets plus five G is going
to change things far more than we've
ever seen anything change and
understanding where and how to apply it
is going to be critical but just as
important knowing how to separate
segregated and separate the both right
is important because every email y'all
are about to send me is going to say I
have this AI solution and we're using
algorithms yeah of course you are
right and then what what really makes
you different what really sets you apart
but if I didn't do that work if I didn't
sit down and do the AWS machine learning
tutorials if I didn't go on YouTube and
take you know the NYU introduction to
neural networks or whatever I'm not
going to know it I'm not going to be
able to apply it and I'm not gonna be
able to be first and that's fun that's
fun no when I get too kicked ass I'm 22
year old NYU graduate that's awesome you
know
[Music]
if you want more lessons from
billionaire entrepreneurs check out the
video right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there you know I worked
weekends I didn't believe in vacation
and so I I really pushed people to work
hard have you ever met a person who was
a great reader when they were young who
was not successful